To understand the science, we
normally end up concentrating
on the stupid, but
every now and then,
we get the chance to
study at the feet,
or in this case, the
hands of a real expert.
Meet Kevin from Switzerland.
He's going to try and set a
Guinness World Record title
for the fastest
descent of 50 stairs
while walking on his hands.
Good luck, Kevin.
[music playing]
[cheering]
Wow, 14.58 seconds.
I couldn't run it in that time.
Don't forget, the problem
with walking on your hands
is there's nothing to
catch you when you fall,
and for most people,
falling is almost inevitable
[thud]
if you can get up
in the first place.
Ah, that's much better.
[thumping]
Yeah, really well.
I would advise quite strongly
that you don't try this.
The thing is Kevin knew science,
and when you know science,
it's just like a walk
in the park, only
upside down, on your hands,
and not necessarily in a park.
First, he swings
his legs upwards,
generating just enough
angular momentum
to stay balanced upside down.
His arms must be strong
enough to support his weight.
Being upside down can be
disorienting as the vestibular
system located in the
inner ear sends signals
to the brain telling
him he's inverted,
meaning he must concentrate
more to stay oriented.
Going downstairs, he generates
more angular momentum, which he
balances out by
going down quickly
and moving his arms,
his base of support
under his center of mass.